EXPECT TO HEAR FROM FLORIDA
GOVERNOR RON DESANTIS TOMORROW.
>> Dana: COVID LOCKDOWNS ARE
ENDING.
ADOPTIONS ARE ON HOLD FOR
THOUSANDS OF AMERICAN FAMILIES.
THE CLEVELAND ARE TRYING TO
ADOPT A LITTLE GIRL NAMED RUBY
FROM CHINA.
SUPPOSED TO PICK HER UP A YEAR
AND A HALF TO GO AFTER FIGHTING
TWO YEARS TO GET THEIR
APPLICATION APPROVED.
TRAVEL RESTRICTIONS AREN’T
APPROVED FREEZING THE PROPER
SEZ.
WE TALKED LAST YEAR WHEN THIS
ALL FIRST STARTED AND REMIND
EVERYONE HOW OLD IS RUBY NOW
AND HAVE YOU HAD ANY CONTACT
WITH HER?
>> YES, THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
HAVING US, DANA.
WE REALLY APPRECIATE THIS
OPPORTUNITY.
RUBY WILL BE FIVE IN AUGUST.
WHEN WE STARTED THIS PROCESS,
RUBY WAS 2 1/2.
SO IT’S BEEN MANY YEARS OF
WAITING AND WE ARE JUST PRAYING
AND BELIEVING THAT SOME MIRACLE
WE GET HER BEFORE SHE TURNS
FIVE.
>> Dana: WHAT HAVE YOU BEEN
TOLD IS THE REASON FOR THE
HOLD-UP?
>> CHINA IS WAITING ON THE
PANDEMIC SAYING WE WANT TO KEEP
OUR CHILDREN SAFE AND CLOSELY
WATCHING AMERICA AND CASES AND
CLOSELY WATCHING THE VACCINE
AND SO THEY ARE WAITING ON THE
PANDEMIC TO BE OVER FROM WHAT
WE’RE TOLD.
>> Dana: HAVE YOU HEARD FROM
THE STATE DEPARTMENT ON WHETHER
THEY ARE TRYING TO HELP GET
THIS RESOLVED?
>> YES.
SO THANKFULLY OUR SECRETARY OF
STATE HAS BEEN SO WONDERFUL AND
THEY HAVE BEEN IN CLOSE CONTACT
WITH THE CHINESE EMBASSY AND
JUST REALLY TRYING TO GET US ON
A PLANE AND THE MANY FAMILIES
THAT ARE WAITING TO GO GET
THEIR CHILDREN THAT HAVE BEEN
PROMISED TO THEM.
SO THEY ARE TRYING AND DOING
EVERYTHING THAT THEY CAN BUT AS
YOU KNOW, IT IS JUST CONTINUING
TO HIT A WALL.
>> Dana: NOAH, ARE YOU
CONCERNED ABOUT THE GROWING
TENSIONS BETWEEN THE UNITED
STATES AND CHINA POSSIBLY
DELAYING THIS EVEN FURTHER?
>> YOU KNOW, DANA, HERE IS WHAT
I BELIEVE AND HERE IS WHAT I
KNOW MY WIFE BELIEVES.
WE TRUST GOD AND HE ALONE GETS
THE LAST WORD AND SO WE CAN BE
FEARFUL OF WHAT IS GOING ON
WITH CHINA AND THE U.S.
MANY TIMES WE SAY GOD, CAN YOU
MAKE A WAY BUT HERE IS THE ONE
THING WE KNOW IS THAT GOD IS
GOOD AND WE HAVE PEACE.
IT IS WELL WITH OUR SOULS.
THERE IS AN OLD SONG CALLED IT
IS WELL WITH MY SOUL AND WE
HAVE PEACE.
NO MATTER WHAT’S GOING ON IN
THE WORLD WITH CHINA AND THE
U.S., GOD, JESUS ALONE GETS THE
LAST WORD.
>> Dana: IVY, TELL US WHAT KIND
OF INFORMATION DO YOU GET ABOUT
HOW RUBY IS DOING?
>> WE DON’T GET A LOT OF
UPDATES BUT WE GET THEM ABOUT
EVERY SIX MONTHS OR SO.
SINCE THE PANDEMIC HAS HAPPENED
WE HAVE GOTTEN PROBABLY TWO
VIDEOS, MAYBE THREE PICTURES.
AND FROM WHAT WE GATHER SHE IS
DOING GREAT.
SHE IS THRIVING AND SHE DOES
NOT HAVE ANY ISSUES THUS FAR
AND SO WE ARE SO GRATEFUL FOR
THAT.
OBVIOUSLY MY MAMA HEART WISHES
I COULD HOLD MY BABY, WISHES
THAT I DO NOT HAVE TO BE APART
FROM HER.
MY MAMA HEART HATES THE FACT
THAT HER ROOM HAS SAT EMPTY.
LOTS OF CLOTHES, LOTS OF LITTLE
BOWS THAT SHE HAS YET TO BE
ABLE TO WEAR AND ALL THOSE ARE
TRIVIAL THINGS.
IT IS VERY HARD TO WALK BY HER
ROOM AND SEE THAT NOT KNOWING
THAT WHEN SHE IS GOING TO
OCCUPY IT.
NOT KNOWING WHEN I WILL BE ABLE
TO GET THIS CHILD THAT WE HAVE
FOUGHT SO HARD TO GET.
THE TRUTH IS, WE HAVE JUMPED
THROUGH ALL THE HOOPS.
WE HAVE PAID ALL THE FEES, WE
HAVE DONE ALL THE THINGS THAT
HAVE BEEN REQUIRED OF US.
SO WE ARE JUST SITTING AT THE
EDGE OF OUR SEATS WAITING AND
PRAYING AND BELIEVING THAT
TODAY COULD BE THE DAY,
TOMORROW COULD BE THE DAY.
ANY DAY SOON COULD BE THE DAY.
>> Dana: I KNOW YOU HAVE VERY
BIG HEARTS AND I HOPE THAT
SOMEBODY IN CHINA WILL LISTEN
AND HAVE ONE AS WELL.